- So, you obviously know Jim and James.
- I know, I've met Jim once or twice.
We've hung out a couple times.
You've come to a couple of shows.
This is very exciting to be, you know--
- Oh, that's right.
'Cause you're the animation,
so you didn't actually do a scene.
You were in a booth.
- They put me in a booth.
They put me in a booth.
- [James] They do a movie--
- [Jim] He makes sound--
(laughing)
- [Ben] in front of nobody.
- You had the best job
because you could be in
pajamas doing your job.
- Oh, yeah.
I was literally like in
an old school nightie
with a candle and a hat.
(laughing)
Going around like Ebenezer Scrooge.
- Why are you a Golden
Girl? Okay, I'm sorry.
(laughing)
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I dressed like all three
of the Golden Girls.
- Yeah.
- Hot.
I like it.
- Yeah, thanks!
- So hot! Love it.
So, we also worked together
and we never met because we both--
- Yes, I was in a booth for that, too.
- Yes, for Home. So I
did the voice thing, too.
Yeah, we never met.
- I played an animated version of myself
singing about Hanukkah, so.
(laughing)
- I played an animated version of myself
you know, just singing Christmas... Yeah.
- Christmas and Hanukkah!
- Yeah, yes, yes.
And it was very hard. I went method.
- Oh, really?
- Playing myself was difficult.
So, your mom, though,
is a teacher like mine.
And I love my mother so much.
- Yes.
- And I love teachers.
And you're a hardcore
lover of your momma, too.
Right?
- Yes, I love my...
It'd be very weird if this was the moment
that I said I hate my mom.
- [Kelly] No, no, no, no, no!
(laughing)
- Happy Valentine's Day!
- Happy Valentine's Day, mommy!
- No, I meant like...
- My mom?
I'm happy we're doing this.
Mom!
- Mommy issues show.
- Can we turn the lights down?
- I start shaking.
- [Kelly] No, cause I read--
- I love her.
- I read your pre-interview
and they brought up
that oh, her mom is a teacher, too.
And you were like, "I love
talking about my mom."
And me too.
- Yeah, she's been a Bronx
school teacher for 50 years.
- [Kelly] Wow!
(audience cheering)
That is so cool.
- [Jim] Wow.
- So you guys were very kind.
And you're like, my mom's
name is Joan Schwartz.
And one of things, they were like,
"Is there a picture of you and your mom?"
And I noticed that all the
pictures of me as a kid
have my name on the shirt.
(laughing)
Made me feel like,
they just didn't remember
my name or something weird.
- You have 17 brothers and sisters.
- [Kelly] Now, were you the last born?
- They didn't want to get confused.
- Yes.
They'd tell me, "Which
one are you? Ben, got it."
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So you're also a published
author. That's crazy.
- I've published four books, yeah.
(audience cheering)
- Did you know that?
- [Kelly] Do you have a life?
- I did not know that.
- You published four?
- I know your name is Ben, though.
- Wow.
- Yeah, I was the publishing
house that published the books.
Oh, no. Yeah, I have four books.
But they started off as these books that,
it would be the cutest, it was called
"Grandma's Dead: Breaking
Bad News and Baby Animals"
- [Kelly] Oh, we have
"Grandma's Dead" here actually.
Yup, "Grandma's Dead".
- [Ben] And it's like the
cutest picture of an animal
and it's supposed to break ...
- Or, it's syphilis.
- It's syphilis is on the back.
(laughing)
It breaks bad news with a cute animal.
So you can say anything terrible and--
- Your baby's ugly?
(laughing)
- [Jim] Aw, nice.
- I made that many, many
years ago, a decade ago.
- Oh my gosh! So wait,
they're postcards you can send
to someone to just cheer them up.
- Yes, so that way it
like softens the blow.
- [Kelly] It's not me,
it's you (laughing).
Are you in need of a card, Jim?
Do you need to tell anyone anything?
- Oh geez, yeah, so many, so many.
- Maybe, well, not this one but,
"You're not the father?"
(laughing)
- I haven't seen this book in a decade
which makes it even more
exciting that we're looking--
- It'd be better if it
said, "I'm not your father."
(laughing)
- That'd be a tough one to grab.
- Yes, but it'd be funny, I'm very dark.
(laughing)
So Ben, we've got animals coming up,
are you an animal person?
- I love animals.
- [Kelly] Me too.
- Yeah, I very much love animals.
I'm afraid of maybe one or two.
- [Kelly] What are you afraid of,
so I can bring it out?
(laughing)
- Are you guys afraid of animals at all?
- Cougars.
- Cougars (laughs), yeah, mountain lions,
you know what I mean, elephants.
- You guys are wimps.
- Grizzlies.
- I don't love snakes,
but I can deal with them.
- Oh, I'm not a huge fan.
- And big, tarantula-y type,
I worked at the Bronx Zoo for a summer.
- I worked at the Fort Worth zoo.
- Really?
- Yes, for a summer.
- Oh my goodness.
- Tell me more
- Okay
- I worked by the monkeys--
- [Jim] Here comes the
zoo talk (laughing).
- And it smelled so bad.
- Yes, I worked at the petting
zoo for a little bit, too,
cause it made me feel like I had--
- It seems cute and then
all you smell is crap.
(laughing)
- Yeah, all you do is shovel crap all day.
But it was very--
- I got kicked out of a pet store.
- [Kelly] No, you have to
have a degree to shovel crap.
- Okay, I love this story, what happened?
- For licking an iguana.
(laughing)
- Why did you lick an iguana?
- Just for fun.
- Okay.
- You don't know what an
iguana tastes like. I do.
(laughing)
- I'm good with my imagination
on that one (laughing).
(audience clapping)
- What does an iguana taste like?
What is lick--
- It's hard to compare.
- [Kelly] Like chicken?
- Little bitter.
(laughing)
- It's its own thing, yeah.